to pick your stream but when you hit go live you have to wait okay we're gonna
let it break first hi everyone welcome to the stream it's me and there are many
Scottish people in the world I'm her favorite thank you very much good
morning good evening good afternoon you know how the drill you know the drill
boys you know the drill I wrote refling's behave refling's and snippet
we exchange little hands today a tentacle and a hand has been exchanged for
mercy and strong are together so hello snippets and hello refling's behave
today we're gonna play untitled goose game yeah and we are obviously expo we're
MLG Xbox players so we're playing on controller have no idea if that makes a
difference to this game but that's not gonna stop us at all like at all so we
can jump right into it I believe thank you barrel for the fire I'm a barrel
thank you for the fight for mayor say that's going in a moving out fund thank
you for funding we were trolling I was like you do not have to meet whenever
you want to say like thank you to someone who like tips you on stream or
anything like that you don't have to mute if anything I'll join in and say
thanks cuz it's funny you like that I find it entertaining when streamers are
like thank you for the 10 10 gifted members thank you you did it
hmm are we jumping in are you ready yeah I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready let's
make sure which one's me which one's you I am I'm the orange one you're the red
one wait why is that automatically is that lag wait we're moving together I'm
not doing that we are I'm not doing that wait but I am doing 360s on the spot oh
no it's there any tea for the for the 20 super chat on moving out fun say less
it's there in a way that's because of is this because we're so mercy and beautiful
did they know you're Canadian yeah yeah merci's Canadian internet connecting to
it let's trigger let's trigger oh my god this game is lagging out this game is
lagging out I will take this way I see you're controlling me right now when
you do that oh my gosh bend down to pick things up off the ground hold bend
down touch your toes and just like to the rhythm of the death what you got a
can oh you're picking up litter can I jump oh my god hold a it makes you zoom
meow meow meow oh my god the lag is so bad but that's not gonna stop me yeah we
are monsters oh my god I can't get it oh my god oh we just tried to be so
smart I don't I don't think the farmers gonna appreciate that to be honest I'm
glad and press rate trigger to spread oh my god we're like love baby oh my god
do you hear the music too I do not hear the music what the heck you don't have
in-game sound you know you're okay why don't I have in-game sound oh no is it
because I'm no no give me a second okay I think you should hear ambience I can
stream it to you via discord so you have in-game sound I think my volume for the
game is just low because I can hear it but it's very shiny someone's asking a
goose for goose girl for Gen 2 absolutely not no I will reject your
suggestions for Gen 2 live don't think I won't I will why are everything why
don't I have sounds I don't I can share on this the old if you want and then it
should come through you think I'll be like behind the possibly I mean we can
try and see what happens this is a terrible idea if I share screen no goose
girl no slime girl wow they're so sad I don't everyone one slime girl am I
missing son also share application audio yes go live right check out discord and
see if you can hear okay okay okay oh on most is actually a lot easier I can't
believe it I won't use my I'm an egg you hear that snippets do you hear me
why can't I hear it is it my is it me am I the problem oh no they don't hold on
hold on I got this I got this baby oh my god it's a Scottish game can't believe
we're in Scotland there's tartan down in the bottom corner okay I think Mercy's
controllers registering as both players if you're using remote play that's
hilarious because I can still control me but Mercy can control both of us and
how in lore friendly is that yes there so you can control me at any time oh wait no
I'm the siren wait a minute yeah apparently your controller input is
changing into mate I'm the one that's supposed to be hypnotizing you here
what the heck the lore the lore I've been main broken by Merchie why it's not
what is it shade on dish called stream paused swap your application to continue
strutman
oh hold on I need to go into my steam settings shit oh no it's me mercy it's
me
it's knee flings knee flings the sneaklings must wait as we are we are
we are ready for trouble prepare for trouble someone says prepare everyone says prepare
for trouble and make it double make it double strongy
mercy thank you iron reaper for the $25 how did you see that wait did he give me 25 as well
yeah oh my god them move up move up to protect the world from devastation
right hold on it's me it's me it's me I'm fucking up the game
it's okay enable advanced host options a play audio okay and if I but how about now
you hear something now we're done
going through my freaking I'm worried it's going through my my um your speaker my that's it
my my controller your controller can talk
look
sorry I think my system yeah that's right
you for the super chat 20 super chat moving out fun tell but I move these funds over to
my darling kohai thank you I think oh my gosh I'm so I'm so what's what's the word they
used to say in the day pepega oh pepega yes pepega I don't know where you're going
where that right okay I can close that because that does look right okay it says I am streaming
the remote play audio to you now whether or not that's true or not maybe a fib or you know that
I'm a little goosling short and stout thank you peenish for the I don't know what this currency is
what is it id r id r id r Dominican Republic wait what I don't know thank you so much don't
forget us when you move to Quebec at tabernac oh tabernac cubicos cubicos cubic mersey and emi
were making fun of me for the way I say cubic and I'm like I say cubic cubic so we now I see
how it's spelled I say cubic cubic for some reason the volume's just not working on my end
kind of weird hmm and the and the stream I mean I was going to say we can play power
washer but mersey gets first person motion sick so we actually can't quite play power
washer the way others might um Danny reset reset are we lobby
your idea I have streamed the game audio to you so I don't know why your discord discord can't
hear the audio as well my discord can't hear the audio and oh but I the monitor sound is as high as
it can and if it if I make it any higher you're going to you're going to sound a lot I'm going to be
a bit too much now don't get me wrong I do appreciate stop streaming turn on please turn on
I said start on webcam I don't think mersey wants to see that first thing in the morning I'm gonna be
um
oh I just accidentally left a voice call there you totally didn't notice that good good yeah
that's that's actually good because I fucked up right untitled good scheme also share application
audio yes at mersey right go live and then go on discord and open up that stream that I've just
given you if that does not give you the audio I am stumped for what we're supposed to do okay
I can hear it can senpai's hear that it might be a little low
I heard it it's such a quiet honk oh you can hear my weak one my weak one
okay hold on let me wait if it's too quiet I wonder why it's too quiet
how about that how about that it's still quiet but it's here like I said it's a little low
the tiniest honk oh no I can't move my volume any any higher either that's the problem
she's gonna um maybe if I can move the monitor sound up I mean I can do it one more time one more time
I
do you hear that bell I hear no the tolling bell is coming for us jeez that's pretty good
okay yeah input for some reason mersey can also control me in the game I don't I don't know
how you've managed that but we have literally I can retake control of myself if I want but
every time you move I'm fighting against you in your pearl yandere like holy crap you've literally
main broken me to do thy bidding and I'm not supposed to be the hypnosis here how are we supposed
to play under these conditions quick let's make a heart with our with our beaks I don't know uh I
can face you like this oh we're kidding do you kid I forgot how to honk again x wait
uh right we're completely forgotten wait there was a picnic down here it looked like uh Scotland
like it's Scotland oh whoa oh wait our wings are up so thanks we're going to war but we're not
oh oh my god let's give a huggy little hug huggy I can't really hug you because every time you
move towards me it pushes me away from you because of the control our powers of attraction are too
with our wings out I we literally wait you control my wings as well
my I copy everything how have we done this I have no idea I don't think I've ever seen this
is this supposed to happen I'm playing with an extra challenge oh this I have no idea what
this game is about by the way so this will be interesting B is to open the stuff so can we open
this oh my god Ned thank you for the gift of 10 holy crap thank you oh mercy is discovering I
appreciate that Ned but you're supposed to give it to mercy because she's moving up oh my god we're
doing gardening aw gardening hold left bumper is a mouth oh that's wrong oh oh there's a man across
the wall do you see him yeah yeah yeah can I can I jump are you gonna swing you put the water on
yeah wait why is it coming out to us oh we're getting jumped we're getting jumped
right can we open up this fence no it's locked from the other side wait can geese no fly
what's going on here wow oh I keep you push me through into the secret
you push me into the H secret I don't know how you did that but that's so good
I'm literally I'm no good control this is amazing
I'm gonna jump them I'm jumping them
why no no no no leave leave mercy alone she's discovering a box is she not allowed to play
about a box what took his keys oh no where did I go with the keys I made a great mistake I'm cornered
I'm cornered hey I did my game okay okay but where are we supposed to put the keys
I don't know oh sorry I guess we just run with the keys I mean wait how do we know what that
checklist is I saw stuff oh my god I'm fighting against mercy so much right now trying to control
myself I can't oh there's I can go uh B B B oh yeah I'm getting jumped he's jumping me he's jumping
us oh my god we got it you got it oh I'm going I'm going I don't know I'm gonna go back to the fence
oh the pumpkin oh the cabbage right is this oh get to the fence oh okay success how or what do we do
with it is my question I'm good oh we cause problems on purpose oh okay now we take it uh
where oh make the groundskeeper wear his sun hat okay what does that say rake in the lake
have a alright okay we can do that rake in a lake yeah okay we can do that right uh
is there a rake in the garden yeah there is oh wait maybe the key is for the fence that was over here
don't you dare use that to trap me you fool he wouldn't do that is he a mean I don't think he's
me oh the gate's already open where the heck is a rake oh there's the rake you've got it
how did I pick up again B A B B if we're going for a pick yeah B like press on all left trigger B
I'm stealing the goods I got the I got the goods for the picnic don't worry get the foods on me
no no no leave mercy oh she's almost gone give me the give me the cooler give me the
no leave mercy I'm totally fighting against the current okay I might just have to
it's still I leave my mercy alone wait no no there's the I don't think you can get it I
think you have to push it through the oh I'm now just following you out this I'm stuck
okay the game
is there there's a there's a there's a gate here that you can pull it from
I don't think we can do it through the fence we must be wise we must be oh so smart I'm stuck in
there are you actually stuck oh thank you he's not tall for the 50 super didn't catch the bit
about moving out at the start I was AFK but this should be good for moving out money right thank
you so much all right give me this oh give me the rake wait is it actually stuck wait wait can
he pick it up can you pick up the rake probably pick it up can you pick up okay thank goodness whoa
whoa he pushed you through right okay that's good there's a gate down here I assume we grabbed
the I like how he's just watching us cause me he made him but he's like happy to just let us go by
give me what's with these kids can we open that open the door yeah I was gonna say can you
reach up and open that or is that no open it for us open for us
oops this there's a hammer on top of the wall that seems dangerous actually what's this
wait maybe we can go on this chair yeah let me move this chair over if I if I fight the tide
I'm fighting the I'm so strong no the chair doesn't move ah okay okay maybe you can go on the chair
I don't think we have the ability to jump we can open our wings but
the best I can do I can open my wings you get through the gate by doing the tasks on the list
oh my god okay so we're region locked right now okay okay we got it see you know this is so
chaotic I cannot believe I somehow managed to get your controller inputs on me I don't
okay we pull it out here got it got it you gotta get we gotta get where is it again I don't see
him right we're grabbing it let's go let's get the heck out here okay okay come push it come this way
this way all right you you can pull me you can like pull us both yeah yeah remember you can pull me
oh no oh no he's like right there no no no no it's not what it looks like it's not what it looks
like give me that rake it's not it's not what it looks like sir stop stop but I demand by the
in the name of the okay get the rake get the rake get the rake get the rake you can do it
left trigger b left trigger b push me down push me down mercy no give me that
leave it no don't you close that gate we need to open give me that give me it oh we've locked him
out his own garden right drop the gate you don't need it give me this you don't need it and you
don't have keys now what like let go I'm gonna let me go yeah yeah yeah yes right oh yes yes yes
you want it so badly don't you yes you do yes you don't want it so badly no no give me the rake
take that fertilizer mercy pick up pick up the fertilizer right yeah yeah oh sugar i'm stuck on his
why are we so coordinated badly with this okay we made progress we made progress i'll take it
okay let me pick up this fairy oh my god it's because of the input wait if i disconnect if i
disconnect my controller is it gonna oh i don't want to reset i uh i don't want to accidentally
resell us no don't go i wonder what happens oh i want to drop the sandwich how do i drop it
yeah yeah you do a picnic right yes right drop the rake yes you care so much about this that's
good i don't care about it leave me alone okay if you get the rake i'll pick up the fertilizer if i
can fight against it wait let me put the fertilizer in my mouth okay i'm holding the
fertilizer he should come to me now you pick up the rake you pick up the rake you can do it
you can do it yeah shove in the lake get that rake in the lake get that rake in the lake
he takes it off me so quickly uh okay we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it oh hello
hello yes yes yes yes yes yes easy easy if you make the other player player one that
should fix it um i actually it took us quite a miracle to get into this game i'm not gonna lie
uh i might just let mercy control me and open my wings we i will take where the wind glides me
the wind is gliding me to this gate i hopefully i'll be fixed um in the next round is it rounds
i don't even know how many maps there are okay let's see if i can help here uh
our foods how much do we need for the game to oh i missed it's okay but kick it in
that wasn't it bring to the picnic a pumpkin a carrot jam tomato radio is that it is in the radio
oh there i was gonna say i was like nah that doesn't look like a tomato to me right do we
need to go through the fence we do we'll probably have to go through the the tiny little thing again
there's only one map this game was so expensive and you're telling me there was one map
here we love causing problems on purpose i'm the better hunker i said it okay uh these are
the cabbages right was that a pumpkin i thought it was a pumpkin wow those are do we need pumpkins
or cabbages i'm gonna grab this one right here okay i got it no i don't want to let the farmer
back in see if he can go through the thing so the gate himself oh he just opened the gate
okay right can i not bring this wait can we not be off screen at the same time
oh wow we can oh i didn't realize i'm pushing you off the screen and you're you're allowed to
okay yes we need pumpkin i don't know if there's like jam in the garden somewhere any
probably but you got the pumpkin yes we can mark pumpkin also what is this a monument i'm at
oh it is a monument it's like a little shrine oh wow okay the gate was open i did not have to go
all of that way but do you want to pick up a carrot while you're there we needed a cow it for the
the pick and pellet yeah are we cow it i want to kill it left trigger me hello yeah that's it
left trigger me hey it's probably i'm not gonna lie we're probably ice skating as well on top
because of the lag wait he took the carrot off of you man don't be a sticker you're in the garden
with me oh literally there's always enough for both the uh am i gonna have to distract him i think
hold on let me get this on the
give us the carrot give a carrot give it back it's not yours
i got it i got it i'm stuck in the lawnmower wait oh no don't pick it up oh my god no i'm
getting manually over read by the frickin input oh i'm stuck i'm stuck i'm stuck no no give it back
give it back you smell give it back that's mine look if it goes on the picnic thing then it's
mine stinky faint okay moment literally oh i see the jam gosh can we even beach that
i will flood your garden now
oh no he's going for the pumpkin leave the pumpkin out of this you have goose in your garden
oh no no no leave her alone right well if you're gonna do that at least give me the
carrot oh no i have terrible news i think we're actually gonna have to reset i don't
think i can play with these controls okay okay i'm willing to reset yes okay we can probably
speedrun this to be honest i have no idea hold on i'm gonna hide my game just in case i show
anything that i shouldn't i i need to hide my game input uh if i quit and then invite you on
local co-op that should work right surely surely wait game two just in case my game capture
now senpai's can't can't you can't see let's do funny things oh you've done mouse and keyboard
did you mean to do that wait no that was me that did that because i was dumb yes it was me i was
like hmm you did that so fast mercy i don't remember inviting you hmm i think it's because
we're still there do you are you still in this instance or do i need to send you a new instance
no that was you that was me that was you okay i think it should be fine now okay hold on right
you move around and let's get out of this bush first senpai they're blind now oh yeah they are
blind there we go what game capture i will wow how bizarre wait is this like is this a bug
how strange right i'm just gonna do mouse and keyboard give me one more shot mercy one more
shot just give me one more chance i will do mouse and keyboard and because i think that's what's
clashing for some random reason i take that i don't need that in my pc okay begin to player
i would like to use mouse and keyboard and mercy reviews controller okay we did it we need to
probably swap who player one is i was player one last time i think okay space bar is home
i mean who needs to quickly relearn all of the
are we the only player one one's an experience to ever have this bug before this is crazy
oh my god game literally unplayable do you think i can get a refund hmm wink wink
how right how do i make you oh right one more am i too powerful give me literally give me one
more chance i'm on my knees give me one more time this is all i ask can you okay now they're
suggesting you go first the game with controller off and then join in okay we're trying we're trying
okay controller off this is bizarre there's only two of us and you want to get them get them boys
take that man's carrots right now okay i mean okay your game controller i will do mouse and
keyboard i will play it safe i am on mouse and keyboard mercy is player one as evidence by
oh i'm the red one now okay use the mouse to click wait
that could are we are we separate people now i think we are i'm separate yeah okay we can actually
cause some mayhem let's go press control yeah okay i've played college before you don't have to
tell me to us wow pick things up okay we can actually play now whoo only took us 30 minutes
to be able to play i honestly now we are i just stop a little literally uh
oh wait it's not like wasd i keep accidentally like zooming in and out like really dramatically
we love oh you guys are playing sorry i forgot you guys are playing sorry sorry it was just
straight up playing the game without you guys seeing sorry i love scrawny cuddles any i feel
like we are so clumsy who's the pornist of the mom mirror mirror on the wall right we'll
sail the ponies of the mall yeah we'll sail the picnic still me for a after i actually
i'm inclined to believe that's true that mercy is the pornist out of us all but i think that's
adorable i mean come on a dorky and dairy that's porn how are you supposed to how are you supposed
to resist are you supposed to resist something exactly what kind of sandwich it's got green on
a sandwich okay there we go i hope there's no mayonnaise in this i'm allergic
oh yeah you can't have eggs like any kind of egg yeah her mercy can you have none
can i take the the cloth here too wait come back come on no not you i mean me
i made him okay so we had to make him wear okay this must be the radio so i'm gonna grab
that we need it yeah at the picnic thing oh may i yes oh if i had aim bought i oh i keep doing
wasd it's not w i'm having a stroke it's not wasd i need to take my fingers off the keys
right uh crouch and then click yes you can't wait it distracts him
wow yeah unlock that gate oh i'm out of range stop making noise little thing
stop making noise it's gonna give it away i don't oh no why did i pick the heart well
maybe we can grab the jam or something while we're at it hold on let's grab the jam let's
grab the jam or key or carrots or anything right jam jam jam jam it was like up here wasn't it
over there oh give me a try to grab a can of each i'm tiny i can grab this i feel like he's gonna
notice me grabbing such a lot yeah let me grab the carrot first though hey well let's get the carrot
first any progress is good progress you take the carrot i'll see if i can grab a pumpkin
where am i where am i oh i lost myself come on come on i've got the pumpkin
this is freaking much more than the hell
we don't need any breakfast right now holy moly this game is not easy
it's really not easy this is kind of hard to control i'm literally having a stroke right now
i'm like keep using wasd but it's for freaking zoom in and out for some reason
right you got the carrot i need his keys give me the keys
oh no he took it off wait how did you take it off me i just grabbed them
i'm stuck control me oh hold on let me see what's going on over here
i'm trying to get the thermals there we go oh you want to look at me no no you want to look at me
no no no leave leave mercy alone i'm so freaking slow at this game leave her alone leave her alone
leave her alone leave her alone give me your leave me your not nope you don't want the thermals
oh sorry i'm i'm going not something wasd thing else yeah wait he let me join the keys
get out get out get out get out of the garden this is so hard hold on hold on i can't move
it's impossible door stuck door stuck
uh where'd i put the keys i didn't even know i'll put them by the gate why not put them like way
over here so if he does come out he goes like right here yeah what do you mean what what do you
mean sam pie you're like mercy come on oh no he noticed it quick grab something else
wait he's gonna go all the way to it wait do we need to fill up the water can for him
no give me the water can look i can fill up the water can for you look it's like teamwork come on
we love everything we love agriculture oh oh wait whoa i got the job i got the job
pick it up pick it up pick it up pick it up oh and i'm completely messing it up
oh my god i forgot about the rake oh the you give me this
i got the job i got it oh god he's coming he's coming oh i'm locked out because of the
freaking render distance no no sir sir give me the jam you want me no no sir i assure you
grab something else we'll grab something else oh yeah you know we need it for a picnic you
don't understand i can't i can't speak human language i can only honk violently just give me
the jam honestly if a bird was like here here here oh no oh no you grab the jam i'm trying
no sir he's chasing me
leave me to the jam right we'll do the rake maybe the rake in the lake yeah we've
left them the rake in the lake why oh you pick that's my radio pick up pick up at the jam
our radio why is the jam not why is the rum always gone why is
it was a mistake it's not really thievery if you don't need it you won't notice it's gone
honk violently does it just stun lock them if you honk oh it does here here grab the jam
i got it i got it i'm out i'm out i'm out we're freedom freedom yeah okay uh i can't go
you're getting pushed off of it while he's holding it oh my god we actually got the jam
now there's only like a billion other things to do so one was like mommy did it it's one map
apparently but there's five sections I have no idea if I'm smart enough to do all five sections
um but we can try what smartness do we need we have like brains the size of I don't know like a
peanut what do we oh sorry what does that say have a picnic rake in the lake we just need a radio
okay if we need to rake in the lake then don't mind me I'm grabbing this excuse me uh you're coming
with me uh excuse me sir sorry excuse me uh have you thought about maybe not
I love the honk feature sir please have you considered not radio
can I escape like this no stop standing up leave
this is impossible sure I'm sure there's like a speed run strategy and someone's like done it in
like 18 minutes flat nothing else I think we're it's because we're having problems with the controls
um oh I mean progress progress the rake is getting closer to the lake nope stop it
stop it I want the rake give me the rake don't you shoot me away give me the rake here here
you're crafting with the radio I got it I got it no my radio this definitely should be a split
screen game because I literally cannot progress until you come right game devs that's a point down
game devs uh for not letting the co-op player progress we got it we got it we got it we got it
and then oh yeah okay he's not chasing after us so we're safe there we go yeah and last but
oh can I at least yes please uh last but certainly not least the radio now if I just honk at him
and distract him hi no uh hello I am mr goose I would like to teach you all those things about
geese did you know that geese are very good people and we are not stealing your larger
container at all behind me please do not look behind me um uh we totally don't need your radio
or you got the radio no no no no there's no no no there's no radio please listen to me thank you
for listening to me so conversations about geese did you know that we're actually very good avian
birds and that um our feet our feet actually transformed into flippers to help with us gliding
when it comes to the water um and swimming in water and stuff and we've actually adapted very well
we have we have corkscrews corkscrews please let me teach you about the corkscrews sir
ah please it's really important okay okay yes yes look at me look at me look at me look at me
yes yes yes right uh left trigger b to pick up the radio now please listen to my corkscrew
rant so did you know that uh female ducks unfortunately um in when it comes to nature
when it comes to nature sir please just a moment of your time when it comes to nature
when it comes to nature um female ducks actually can't um you know reject uh unfortunately because
of the doggy dog world okay thank you for your time goodbye i think we did it we did it we did it
we did it oh we can enjoy our picnic together oh we can do what are you having first to eat
i think i'm gonna have uh the pumpkin you're pumpkin uh i'm gonna have good jam and bread
wait is that bagpipes laying on there
is that actually bagpipes
kind of sounds like that but i think i can hear the snare drum and the drone which makes me think
this is genuinely bagpipe music oh no oh no this can't be it is oh well we completed our objective
whoa sorry sorry that was me
instagram's keeper hammer his thumb what oh um his thumb well well we had our little picnic
yeah um i'm not sure how we're doing that and we waddled away waddle waddle so the very next
part of the mission bum bum bum bum bum bum bum the geese walked up to the gardener's garden
and he said to the man when they learn about corkscrews hey bum bum bum let us steal your
what what's this no geese he said no geese this is geesist how dare you yeah this is geesist
how do i make him hammer his thumb i'm not sure
anyways i'm gonna do some guiding now it's my garden it's our garden oh are you starting a farm
what would you grow what would you grow i must know you must tell me i'll i'll grow strawberries
because they're easy how do we he's not hammering did we just watch him do what he wants to do
he's not hammering anything oh maybe he's gonna hammer the sign where would i if i was a mean
farmer where would i put the sign yeah where are you gonna put it show me
are you gonna put it man are you gonna put it i'm not sure oh oh okay he's getting the hammer next
so i need to get out of the way excuse me sorry i'll get out of the way i guess when he
hammers just honk get ready steady
oh no okay no okay we wait ready
yes okay okay that makes sense that makes sense
whoa we made a pass out are you okay
leave us alone okay we're free we're free where the heck are we going now now we're we're we're in
other territory the tutorial is finished we are now actually exploring the game so this wow
wow this must be when we become menaces to society we have to smart every every
project starts small scale we have terrorized a poor grandpa in his retirement and brought him
close to a heart attack by raising his blood pressure significantly and now we will do it to the math
oh hello football
my gosh tv let me in good morning glenn
honk honk please don't let me in we have we have human monies come to the door
there's a person inside there we would like to spend our human wealth on you for our totally human
money here yes it's totally not leave stuff umbrella stuff yeah i found a weapon oh hello lady
oh you don't seem very nice with it hey
wow buddy jeez some people are nice to nature oh my gosh why are we why are we
why are we disliked so much wait what's on the list oh whoa that's a lot break the broom
break the broom trap a boy in a phone booth what the i mean make the boy wear the wrong glasses
make someone buy back their own item get on tv get on tv and go shopping put in the basket
a toothbrush loo roe loo pick um uh bog roll hairbrush tin food cleaner fruits and veggies wow
there's so much okay there hey i'm walking here hey i'm walking here uh how do i make
ah she like okay she completely throws you out of the area so uh is there something over here
oh no not again oh my god there's like a cute look whoa what you got there
a garbage are you littering you can yeah oh there's apple cores though
yum yum yum for oh wait wait there's the toothbrush right wait you're right ooh we have to buy a
used toothbrush oh i guess i well i guess it's recycled at this point then it's not used
we we love and buy uh i guess back at her shop if we're supposed to buy it i don't want to put
it too close to her shop in case she puts it somewhere oh she's so nasty get her back the basket
up there this basket no that ain't it i must be where you are lady i get it you don't want
oh that's the that's definitely a basket i don't know that's the basket right how do i yeah yeah oh no
yeah okay what's this an airplane what with an air is airplane on the lift sorry hold on
yeah sorry sorry me bad me bad airplane uh loo roe hairbrush tin food cleaner fruit and veg
nothing else if i'm not why is that the boy are we uh excuse me we're here to lock you inside a phone
booth oh no he's scared of us get in the phone booth get in the phone booth yeah yeah yeah
yes there we go now we trap him inside there uh how do we trap him oh that was it oh my god
he's calling for help for his parents oh i feel really bad oh wait his dad is right there opens
oh wait right running when he comes out i guess oh i love tv
wait we're gonna oh we both got chased out right oh
what's going on in here get on tv how yeah i'm tv
i'm honking i'm honking oh wait there's a button there's a button to the left of the window do you see it
okay okay i'll push it oh i'm trying i'm trying oh my goodness camera killing me it's killing me
oh
it's us there's door oh my god we're featuring in the game
oh my god your face is right up to the camera oh my god no okay we got chased out it's fine but
we did what we needed to do to anime girl billy per child honestly oh he's just so scared
pulling poor poor british child why is he british because it looks like a wimp oh i guess because
of phone booth okay i'll allow that one i think british are the only people that say loo paper right
or oh yeah you're right this is a british game all right someone's to buy the wrong glasses or
something i don't know i'm gonna just grab them make him wear the wrong glasses
let me take your stuff wait no wait wait wait oh okay okay
yeah yeah yeah leave me alone mersey's cooking okay i got it
oh no is she gonna see it oh i don't want i don't want her to see it give me those
i don't want to do i think she's gonna see it oh wait if you put the glasses where his toy is
wait why do i want him to chase me toy yeah he's got a toy on the bench i want do you put
glasses on the bench what a confusing game i have to admit i'm i'm a rather confused
like chaos how do i how do i take glasses off of a child
should have made a shout out to the real thing oh no she's not no you're not supposed to see
that she took it oh wait so she didn't see the wait she needs her broom have to make her break
her broom i don't know thank you anonymous i probably should have showed you that i was panicking
oh i've just crossed off the game uh right let's not do that again that was a bad choice right
release oh lord yeah yeah rick i wonder what happens to the cage when senpai's move out of their
cage when mersey moves out uh we gotta make some room right yeah the kids i have a leak
okay this is lure rule i guess i put it in this basket or is she gonna like be raging
it's fine oh there's plants here this is so cute what else do we need the hairbrush
uh a can of something maybe i can't remember i can't remember oh wait why am i see you can grab
her broom like the back of it wait can we rip it apart i think we can hold on let me get behind her
give me that broom give me that i think she'll fight you for it like i know you ain't that strong
you've been you in retail i know how yes give me that broom that's what i think about your broom
you lady getting so good this game is an australian game in melbourne but you terrorize an english
village oh sugar we need the hairbrush and i just completely forgot and i had the perfect
opportunity to grab it because i was reading chat oopsies honest mistake honest mistake don't poke
us with our uh stick like what's going on here how do we buy oh she's fixing the broom wait he just
put his glasses back on why is she's pushing me away by her aura alone uh right so she's gonna fix
the broom that's fine how do i make the child wear the wrong glasses
i mean the glasses are there actually she never took the glasses back
so child do you drop the glasses if we steer you enough
no what are you doing young child
we demand you wear new glasses right now
you are given the gift of sight oh literally what i'm i'm think we're missing some sort of
timed event on him oops oh i remember how to put the glasses on him you gotta go for his shoe laces
oh hold on a minute enemy spotted target spotted we need to go for his shoe laces oh no those are
glegs oops sorry i just picked up the leg wait and then what we push and then we take his glasses
and give them and give them the new ones okay i comprehend all right okay the glasses are now
in the way he should look for can you give him those glasses
and then drop it in front yes oh we did it thank you reeflings we love getting our hands
held through game we did the caustic spirit okay next you look better in that one anyways
yeah this is red uh we need to make someone buy back their own stuff wait did i not put loo paper
in that basket put in the basket we did put in wait so it read oh she put it she took it
man i was trying to buy that what hmm she took it that's why give is give is it back what's this
sure i'll distract her how did she see that she got eyes on the back of her head
like i'm just trying to support your small but local business
so then who is this we're supposed to sell someone and pardon me he was
maybe we take his plane and we put it back and you'll buy it yeah and he'll buy it maybe
i'll like that theory oh everyone everyone calm down
uh oh yeah yeah you're right you're right you're right
ah sugar ah no no no no no no she's not done yet she's not placed it then
wait is she gonna serve him she is i think you did it oh my god you did it right well
having a conversation uh i'm gonna go yank a leak because we need some veggies uh
don't mind me just waddling off oh no the perk he actually did buy it i feel so bad
feel bad but also not yeah i knew to do this has been added
so
why is the music so intense oh god i'm stuck on the edge
i can't fit it all in the
so
i'm running laps around no how can you even notice she's picked something up i'm trying
to explain to you i need this tomato and you're being so rude about it you are you are so
right what do we actually need go shopping tinned food a cleaner and a hairbrush
trap the shopkeeper in the garage the garage oh yeah you said garage don't you wait what
happens with wait she's going in the garage now how do i trap her in oh how do i pull it down we
pull it down oh no i was oh no
help me lady i'm stuck in your gate i'm in the garage me
uh lady question mark are you gonna come see hello have i just softlocked us because of my
i'm just trying to i communicate to her that i'm stuck in here there's no way i did that
the the objective get her stuck in it me instantly get stuck in it is she gonna hear me can she hear
me maybe oh something is there something in here home to get the camera's attention um
um oh she does come and save me okay thank goodness because please help me
wait until she gets inside come in come in come in come in into my secret layer hello i am you see
my goose face i'm no no no no come in come in come in come in come in wait unless i steal an item
and run in with it hold on hold on wait you're not coming you're coming no i never picked it up
no give it back right give me the leak then i won't take this little disrespect
come into the garage lady come into the garage
look we got chase me into the garage no i dropped it no i dropped the freaking thing
oh no i can't no i'm stuck in the set why is this so hard okay oh right i don't think i can get
her stuck inside um what do you want if i get her stuck in say does she reverse kidnapping hoisted
hoisted by you is what hairbrush tin food cleaner
right i can see the hairbrush i'm going for it i said i'm going for the hairbrush no i'm getting
shoved out uh uh okay i got a hairbrush but she's
fucking gunning for me i think we need to lock her in or we can't progress you know that
hold on oh maybe if i can grab her broom she always wants her broom and then we lock her in
yeah okay i'm on standby you must chase her in oh wait i need a honk she's so violent with me
she's so fast
women give me we're both fighting over for the freaking broom okay okay i'll stop fighting
no no no i don't mean like that i just mean she's so strong too geese can't be at best
her oh wait i figured it out oh my god oh my god i figured it out pick it up and run no pick it up
i need to pick up that piece give me the piece or put the piece in the garage
oh my god she keeps shooing me away she's got like a five meter radius aura or something about
her honestly oh right i've got it i've got it are you ready are you ready are you ready
let me run out let me run out she'll take a second to fucking
in
i mean oh no wait what she did she's open it she's doing something
it's open it it's open it aside quick oh there's cleaner i find the cleaner
another there we go there we go i got the cleaner progress progress we got her trapped it's
it's fine it's fine senpai um well this is kiosk no oh my god her pr- wait why are you i just
picked this out of the trash i literally just picked this out of the trash lady leave me alone
i picked it myself thank you jake for becoming a membo i appreciate it
is there right so does it only one a hairbrush and tinted food okay okay hairbrush i can do
hairbrush i'm pretty sure it's like over here okay her bro her broom is in tatters so maybe
she doesn't care that much hmm she cares a little bit here grab it grab it grab it grab it oh my god
please game please cooperate with me a little bit yeah oh do you want to lock her in do you want to
lock her in lock her in and get ready oh shit oh no women you're only supposed to be like leave me
you're supposed to be looking literally no give me that back give me a back
her aura is too strong she like won't she doesn't listen like other npc she's so strong
give me that okay check this over here look at me
ah grab the tint food yes that'll do at least it's progress you are a nightmare lady you really
are i need something wast i'm sorry it keeps making the camera late oh please just work oh thank god
jesus we're done we're done okay now what else oh no look she drew knee ducks on this that's
really rude that didn't appreciate that no let's get let's get that let's get one thing straight
oh oh ow ow give me that all right can we she opened up a gate did we go through the gate
i think we did it granny got new knees no wonder she's so fat yeah
man screw this place i'm going home even though we came from we need trouble anywhere else
hmm you're so rude i know in lake sir welcome welcome raiders welcome to the stream of chaos
uh left or right you're all right oh there's a pond
hmm water water whoa i saw that i saw that did is there a complete little nightmares
confirmation where did you get confirmation time confirmation any little nightmares
oh we love dino nuggies hello mister hi i'm playing with your lacrosse uh well i do
objectives let's see where our objectives are make someone break the fancy vase help the woman
dress up the bust make the man spit out his tea get dressed up with a ribbon make the man go
barefoot do the washing what is are we supposed to go into like different gardens oh wait this
is the man spit out his tea um yeah here's your hat how do we make someone spit their tea out that's
so specific get trapped nude okay he keeps taking his hat back but how do maybe if we wait for him
to get his tea i'm off work and then we can't get him yeah let's do that yeah agreed okay let's
watch this gentleman try and have his tea well hello there
uh oh there's a lady across the fence hi are you friendly is anyone friendly honestly i don't
think so special rules uh uh hello oh the vase the vase see this fucking thing man fuck this thing
and put this one thing in particular uh everything else oh her wee bra's on the
line i know she got wee socks as well uh i'm stoke i'm stoke
hello no no no no hold on the camera movement's making me a little bit dizzy oh no are you feeling
a bit sick yeah give me a moment if you feel too sick it's okay we can we can post up i ain't
gonna force you to play if you feel sick i didn't realize the camera was so unsteady yeah it was just
like oh this is so cute we can just do this
oh
is she gonna break it no oh oh my god let me dress you up oh maybe not hey that's
pharmacy that's literally our bowl that's our entire design i have a bowl on my chest
exactly and technically you're bowing your skirt your skirt yeah it's on the back of your
skirt so i don't oh there's like a wee frog thing oh sorry sorry i didn't mean to take your thing
is a bell uh why do you even have that lady
is that how we break the statue do you notice i have the ball no i notice she doesn't have
i promise i have the soap wait her wait this is a bathroom in this is a garden it's a bathroom
i know this isn't a bathtub wait hey this isn't a well this isn't a lifeguard state
oh no that's not the main way is it this is a bathtub the beach the beach yes yes that's it
what's in the drawer uh oh oh sorry about that oh chat but uh didn't really mean to do that but
hey over here now i love causing problems on purpose
i want to wear a beautiful ribbon i don't i assume i can put it on you essentially
but i want a bizarre come here come here i can put it on you i thought i could put it on you
oh i'm just doing it from you oh we're just passing it mouth to mouth excuse me
oh we're just like here you go no you have it no you have it no you have it you hang up you hang
up you hang up uh i don't know how to get her to break this um no she's always gonna have it
she she goes to an idol meeting in the open literally how what maybe we go in another garden
for now and get out of here wait we can't even get out until we progress through this stage
our section there is a gate here hello mr gate that is not going to work
we have this on you i don't know if you can
i like the way we both look down at it really
that's not the way it should be
okay why can't i not put it on you oh
oh oh you're so aggressive uh no i'm like trying so hard to put it on you right now
it's not working oh wait wait wait oh maybe if i move the duck if we move the geese
and you be the duck yeah and i'll be the i'll be it oh i like this idea and then i stand there
and then she puts it on me unless she's gonna constantly put it okay right i'll let her pick
that up and then i'm gonna yank this away no you don't care about this okay like it's hidden
no oh i just clicked off again i can't stop doing that what no no no no no no no no no no grab the
ribbon grab the ribbon i'm trying oh no you've got me lady wait does she know that's
this she knew
that's wait what how did she know that's not possible what is on me fine but the game
literally says to put her there
the table we broke something about the table we broke hold on what's up with the table
can add a table now this one oh it's how we get out we go up the table now to go into
another garden you want to move on to the next one we can come back to this plot plot we'll come
back to to miss to the garden to miss as soon as we scare the mister we call her miss crack pot
because we have to crack her pot wait literally hi do you have a cup of tea by any chance for us
little geeseling we really like your lacrosse do you want to have some tea a bit of tea no no tea
okay jeez that's hard to impress these people clearly wait hey does he have a does he have a
set of tea maybe hello
hello he doesn't he really looking at us like can i help you uh yeah actually you're a mission
objective we're not doing we're not going to be promised i'm just i'm just crouching around in
your garden i ain't doing nothing what we're doing we're watched through the fence he can't see us
but we can see him perfect we're we're such we're such bad geese literally what is going on
night wait why is he so what's the word he's so suspicious yeah he's paranoid he like can't even
enjoy his tea come on oh oh oh okay rub in the yeah okay okay go go go go go go
no you're supposed to spell it my good sir did i not give you a freighter in that
right take a sip hey hey wait that wasn't what we wanted wait nothing marked we wanted him to spit
out the tea so he has to drink the whole thing i think
no steal his shoes don't have to tell me to it hi oh no i didn't mean to do that i meant steal
your loafers sir yeah i'm sorry them loafers go sit down sir go sit down i want your shoes
oh he didn't like that i like him he's totally like he's tolerating us but he's came to not
uh what no
oh no i missed my turn there can't get it no can you
yeah out of bounds that's that's right you aren't coded to come over here only i'm coded to come
over here but you know oh did he just boot me because i took us through you don't deserve it
maybe use the big bell behind him oh that makes perfect sense actually to do the bell when he goes
for a sip can we see him do a sip from that side one of us has to go on the other side i think
i think we uh i think we both have to do it or else we can um hello i'm at a kakaya hello
excuse me madame i need the bell i shoot madame i need the access to the bell you're in my way
madame madame please refrain from getting in my way right oh sorry okay that's definitely what
you're supposed to do when he sips his tea we just need to hang around while he does his wee tea
okay we're getting there we just need our handheld through the game just a tiny bit okay just a
tiny bit of hand holding right so we need to wait until the suspiciousness is come back
he should he should drink his tea after he's done his like suspicious animation
oh wait i'm trapped i'm trapped we're good i didn't this game is a lot harder than i thought i thought
this was like a i say this about every game i play oh i thought this was a child's game why is it hard
and i don't know if that's just a reflection on me but he's still
no the bell thing needs to be set up again she's not fixing it
oh no you're right oh sugar what is she trying to fix right now oh well okay um she's currently
painting take the bow i didn't know i can take her paint and brush oh i can draw her paint and
brush one or the other good night starting about wake up in four hours bro you're gonna be charred
um no was that supposed to take the paint brush oh she's gonna fix the bell okay
and then do you want to put the duck in the other garden i wonder if that's what it is
you put the statue in the other garden so then she forgets she even had a duck
no i must tell you okay there we go okay it's now out of bounds so she can't ask for the duck
anymore it doesn't work like that and now we wait for him to drink his dang tea that must be frozen
solid at this stage because there's no way please ask for tea are you coming in this garden
your audio might be cutting it for me on discord a little bit
oh sorry no that was all good the knee buddy so she knows it's fake right
she tells you to move does that need to paint you
so she's fixing that wait can i put the bow on you now because we got rid of the statue
no i've done you didn't give me time right go paint right go paint geez let's do this bell for
this poor man oh he's about to do his animation okay no he was supposed to do the drink tea
animation why maybe this will help your mindset for the puzzle the game is meant a single player
everything can be done solo you mean we could be doing this twice as fast but taking us three
times as long hold on a minute what's going on here these allegations oh yes dumb because you're
right i mean it's not wait water in this dish maybe i'm like trying to look around for hints
but i'm like bro stand on the stand when she's not looking right if mersey's distracting her
okay she's i have stood on the stand while she's not looking i am doing no input
as if that was it that took us so long to get the first thing right he's got tea in his hand
dunny ring the bell look at me i'm mersey i have a we're gonna ready yes yeah oh my god that's fun
time it took us so long to get one and then we have to always reallon about the bell see you
i know i'm all right i have a bow like you now
yay the soap what do we do with the soap
why do you have soap outside it was just like a bathtub in a toilet quite literally is her
decorative stuff hold on let me check where objectives are because i'm completely forgotten
now oh sorry that's not objectives make the man go barefoot and do the washing with a bra a pair
socks slippers and a bar so right hold on a minute where would we do washing right i'm going to steal
this guy's other loafer but where do we get water to do the washing let's steal his shoe
because that's super easy hello we would like to steal your shoe please beautiful we do the washing
in here no it's not what it looks like we're not here for your other loafer at all i promise
i promise you can't get me out of bounds
out of bounds talk to the game devs because the face ain't listening
okay oh he won't let me in again right okay well go sit back down because now we need to do laundry
i don't really know where to do laundry put the vase on the man's side of the garden the man will
throw it back over oh we're just straight up against but are you okay if i if we get our hand
held because i don't mind the reefland's spoiling it for me okay we need to drag the purple statue
all the way over uh right we can do it don't mind me i'm not that i'm not that fast lady
whoa
here you go
go scrawny girl
stop on the the fit what let me over okay okay we did it hello would you like to throw this
magnificent uh priceless vase over the fence by any chance or vase vase i don't know i think vase
like vaseline
he actually did wait why are you taking he just stripped me naked give me back
i'm naked how dare you oh i guess we do the washing in here because look there's water
oh my god we're swimming right we need to wait i need to grab the bar brahman
we need the bra and the sockies can we can i quickly grab it this way
maybe i can run no no let's do it this way if she catches me it's fine because at least you've got
wait she's not even upset about the
okay we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it
turns out all we needed was to someone to spell it out for us
wait no he's not going to throw that back over look it's in it's in the water now
no this is mine
it's in the water no no no no no no no no don't do it don't do something
give me give me that it's going in the water for washes yeah that's right you don't want to
stand in this no these are mine there are many things no go have your tea
why aren't you drinking tea a moment ago go forget
forget no no no no hold on no leave mercy be you fellow wench
yes please listen to my problem says the geese oh life is so hard as a ghost you see
people don't oh oh well you know as long as one of us picks up that's the main thing
i'm away i'm away be i'm away i'm away oh no i'm not away oh oh oh no no no no it's not what
it looks like i promise it's not right hold on there i know your neighbors with that again
oh take this sock can you pick up that bar soap that's on the bathtub and the meat i think
we're done like i think we've done it i think we're yeah taking the clothes right as long as
a guy doesn't take a random pair of socks off of us i don't know why he would care that much but i
don't know where he is and the camera isn't zoomed out so i don't know if i'm gonna run into him
is he still oh he's moved the bra out of the freaking thing right let me go get that bra
do not throw that bra over the fence do you understand me give me that bra give that book to
me i need that i'm in my i need my training bro okay is this not what we're doing laundry
wait this wasn't what i'm supposed to do
what is do the washing a slipper oh no i put all the slippers out of bounds oh no i'm backfired
my plan has backfired terrifically hold on hold the lane mercy hold the lane i'm coming mercy
distract him oh hold the lane hold the lane hold the lane i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming
oh hold the lane oh i'm running i'm running i'm running i'm running i'm running i'm running
Oh
Yes
That was freaking hard
I think it's hard
God that camera is so hard to do this make someone
Prune prune the prize roll. I mean it looks like he wants to do it. I'm not really wanting to like make him do anything
What is he writing does that mean we just like honk when he's he's you know
He hit me
Make a no-geese sign. I think everyone's yeah, literally everyone's doing a no-geese every time we're finished in an area
It is right. He can touch the brand stuff. It doesn't matter. How do we is there any gardening equipment?
Hey, hey, you just closed out on my face lady. Don't do that again
I
Is there gardening tools in here? Hello, lady. Do you have it? Oh, I
See it. I see it and I'm messing it up terribly. Oh, this is quite heavy
Hold on lady. Hold on lady. Give me up. See this paint bro. Oh, man. I'm terrible
Can you grab those clippers? Yeah, I'm just gonna excuse me
Have you heard about our savior just make use face very good goose one of the best goose live the first seven years
Which is so big in goose life is?
Thank you for listening to my story
Is that how you is that how you print a rose bush?
Well, we're giving them we mean oh I need to move it
Huh
Didn't do anything
Do we need is there a rose bush we need to like steal from her garden?
Grab the rose pot and drag it next to the shrub then mess up the shrub
Mess up the shrub
Excuse me lady needs to come back in your garden man. Fuck the shrub fuck the shrub. Oh fuck the shrub
You know that make Nicki Minaj song that's like high heels on my tippy and it goes fuck the club
Yeah
Is that all I mean, I'm going for it
Wait he threw yeah, wait is she gonna accidentally chop off the rose? Yeah looks like she is
Oh
No, do you know how long it takes to make roses? It's like a very hard job to have them grow successfully
It takes so long right okay, I'll see worry. Oh, we got the car. We got the problem. Is he crying? He said my rose
Oh
She's opening a panel. She's letting us go out this panel here. She said I had enough of you geese
Sorry we in the way pardon me lady, I don't know what your plan is. Oh
She got no good as well, okay
I actually kind of like that when you're finished with this section the game's like no goose by the way
I think that's quite sweet
Okay, okay. I'm out. I'm out. Gee. I'm done
Thank you. Bye. What's in here? Hello. Oh
Pardon oh
Sorry, I'm sorry. Oh, we're just coming through. Sorry. Just visit and thank you
Oh package. Which package is this? Can we open it?
We can take it away with those hours now
We actually don't have an objective so we're not there yet
This is the wrong way
I'm a porch pirate. Look at me
Yarrg I'm gonna post it in the wrong door on purpose
Yeah, yeah, and then and then they get to talk and then they'll fall in love or something
I don't know. Yeah. Wow. We're so good. We're such good neighbors. I literally
We need geese everywhere. Geese are actually secretly cupid. We're so helpful
We're writing fan fiction. Look at the lavender
Pretty flowers
We love flowers in this house, right? You're the prettiest flower. I've ever seen
Joff I'm blushing. Oh
The camera angle swap in every two seconds. Oh my god, there's a banky ACs in this game
Not this not this look at the bankies for AC
Oh
Right AC needs to play this game. No, just so she can walk around
Wait, wait, hold on to AC's voice again
And today we're going to play goose game with Mercy
Thank you
Oji-sans for watching me and this
My call high mercy and the snippets. This is a terrible voice. I
Cannot do I see at all. I'm trying. Okay. I'm trying. I can't do I see I see it's too unique and too cute
Can't do it like a European accent. Is it too hard to mimic European accent of any kind?
He did French. Did you learn French? Could you you know, can I do it? No, can I learn French?
Bonjour salut like that kind of French. Salut. Oh, I've not heard your French boys
I've not heard your French boys before
Salut merci a va
About me
Your French boys is so cute
To do a avec moi
On title goose game again
Look is the rake
Wait, are we are we done? Did we finish already? No, we can't have
No, we've not
Oh
Help the woman dress up the boss. Oh, no, did we
Wait, no, but she let us go to the next area so
We finished oh, we gotta go back. Oh, no
Oh makes the ground keepers wear his own hat. We don't have that
But we're allowed to move on
How do we make you accidentally went back to the beginning of the game wait, so we need to go the other way to unlock the new map
Hold on Ray. Let's go the wrong way. Let's try the other only we would manage that honestly
Again, try that again. We'll go up
I'll blame the French this time. Let's see. Je ne comprends
Where the fuck we is?
Wait, do we need to go along that bridge there?
No, maybe
I'm
Swimming up the water
To say water and French you say
Why is the French why is water male in French I do not know no
No, I am skinny buying that skinny, you know what I'm saying
Wait, so we're sick where it matters
Yeah, exactly. That's how I like
We're casually just flirting
I say, oh, I remember like seeing like complaints like on feature group collabs
I was just turned into them being nice to each other while you're surprised
Wait, we're surprised that we're nice. You ask you want me to be mean. Yeah, like literally would you thank you Scott?
Literally what you want me to be like all you Canadians with your cube a cost and all that and your friend your fake French like what wait
so we weren't supposed to go here or
What's the deal? I'm a drama
This was the way to go because we opened a gate to get here and there was a new camera angle
Well, I guess we'll move this way now
Moving on up. Maybe it was like a shortcut to go back. I guess a
Bit a bowl of water. Okay. Well considering. Yeah, there's literally an arrow. That's like you're actually meant to go this way
Dumb a oh hey a car. Let's trap someone in it
So, this is how mercy lured her first victim
I put in like hot girls in your area in this truck and you just walked in I can't believe you guys actually
Responded to that ad she put up cute yandere in your area seeking you now two miles away. She's honing in on your current location
Oh
Eat a minute or over objectives get into the pub
Break the dartboard get the toy boat
May say toy boat ten times fast toy boat
Why you say fine toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
Wait, why does it sound like something or a tongue twister? Oh, okay? Okay? Okay? Okay?
Toy boat. How do you say toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat a boat?
Bit of a toy boat moment
little tongue twister like when you say like
10 soldier or something and then you're supposed to say it like 10 times faster 10 soldier
I've never had 10 soldier 10 soldier send 10 so oh
10 soldier 10 soldiers 10 soldier 10 soldier 10 soldier 10 soldier 10 soldier okay, okay?
I've not heard that one. I heard like Peter Piper picked a pick a pickle pick up peppers
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, or like Sally says your shoes. I want your shoes. Oh go for his laces get him where it hurts
Give me that
We're tear we terrorizing them. Oh
I can't this camera angle is so unforgiven. You know that
It really is I keep getting pushed away juice
Do we need to jump in the van and like wait, we need to jump in the box, maybe oh
You're right. Wait, there should be another box in the van. Let's go into your secret kidnap van. How do we
We get in though
How do you can it? Okay, we come in oh
No
It's only one it it's only one at a rate you go you go in before me. I'll be fine you go on without me
Okay, we'll cause troubles later
Yes
I think if you burst out of the box maybe one of you hide in the box when the woman isn't looking close the box and wait until
The delivery woman picks up the box. She will carry you inside the pub
What about me? I just stay outside. I'm literally waiting in line for a queue
I'm pretty sure like people have to queue for like nightclubs or something like that
I'm keen to get in the pub right now
Never I've been to like clubs a few times and I'm just like oh, that's loud music
It's not for me make my ear. Oh, I got these I got these Tism
Earphones where you put in and it makes everything quieter when you go outside if you do not have them
They are so good. They are I cannot recommend them enough. I will literally send you a pair
It makes going outside a heck of a lot easier
Oh
Be careful that's good in there. That's very valuable goods. I make myself clear
Do I make myself clear?
Okay
There should be another box
Am I gonna is the camera gonna thingy out? Oh
No, can you see yourself? I can't move. No, I'm stuck
I'm like to
Did the game devs game devs hello game devs any game devs any hot patch and you have any game dev fixers
I'm not sure I think we might have softlocked ourselves a little bit. I'm not
I'm stuck. I'm stuck
Okay, I'm stuck game. Oh, man. Oh, man. Oh, man. Oh, man. Oh, he just fell over. That wasn't very nice of me
Where are you? I don't know. What? Oh, oh, no
My old panic how on earth do I get to you? There's a hose in there's a little hole here. Yeah, would you call me?
Oh
Let's destroy that dartboard. Oh, yeah, actually we need to play bull's-eye
We're nice geese, I promise we're not oh, we have little game here
The toss the ring stuff. Oh, sorry. Were you playing that sir? I apologize. Oh, sorry. Were you playing? Yeah?
Oh
That's the dart that scream out. I'm winning
one two
three, oh
I'm sorry for distracting you get sir. Why did we destroy that? Oh
I
I get to play a harmonica
How do we destroy a dartboard between us you cigarette, maybe we find something similar
Yeah, oh
Oh
There's like a little podium I night myself the geese of all
Are they clapping for me?
Hello
How do you open your wings? I don't know. Oh
My god, they love us. Oh
My god, I was joking about this being a podium, but we actually got a flower. That's so cute
Oh my god, we're such good geese. We should good job. We should join a circus
Yes, we should join a circus
Okay, maybe geese girl considered for gen two because I adorable okay
Yeah, I'm starting to warm up to anyone
Suggestion to a wasp girl a what oh see bug girls are an issue and I'll tell you why actually development
I don't mind telling you this
Really because of like arachnophobia, for example or insect phobia is a very real thing
It is it has a possibility of putting the girl at a disadvantage
Design one. Oh damn. Yeah, and if you didn't know I don't mind sharing this with you. Um, but you know, how you
Have
That's it no more do you know oh my god, give him the flower you you were amazing. Oh, I can't give him the flower
He doesn't like it
You want to play again
Mr. No, he just wants to look at us. That's fine. Um, oh
So, you know how you have two eyeballs
Yeah, do you want to know I made sure you had two eyeballs because
It's actually really startling if a vtuber only has one eye or there's like a mono eye like monster girl type thing
and it's kind of one of the rules of like
Development is you can't wait. Can she see me under the table and
You must have a girl with like two eyes that isn't too freaky or you're putting them at a severe disadvantage
And like it kind of goes the same for vtubers that might have multiple eye designs
like it's
Unfortunately, just like a weird
What is going on over here are we doing the dishes? Oh
Oh
It's the toilet under table under table. Oh, no, there's no table over here. Leave us alone. Leave me alone. I'm scared
Hold on I want this knife. Hold on. Let me go on. Oh, wow. She's like chasing me all the way out
No, I'm chasing me onto the table. Good luck with that
You look very menacing with a knife in your mouth
Oh
The knife is underneath you. I think what am I to do with the knife?
I don't know. I felt like maybe we can destroy the dartboard with the knife break to the dartboard get the toy boat
Make the old man fall on his bottom
Steal a paint glass and drop it in a canal and set the table knife work plate. Oh
Set what table? Oh, I'm like I'm like proper stuck. Oh, what's this?
I'm currently getting gridlocked my little good
Where are we supposed to set up a table? Oh
There's like a little underway pathway here, I mean a bug girl doesn't multiple need multiple eyes
It's it's kind of hard to like oh my god, I'm like, sorry
Mercy's currently fighting with the cafe owner and I'm like under here like
Well, actually when it comes to the designs and intricateness of having to produce them
Oh, no, don't shimmy out saying you can't get me when I'm under this dog
Wait
People are we supposed to set up wait we're meant to make him fall on his bottom
Oh when he goes to play the harmonic we need to move the chair out of the way. Oh
That's sad. I don't know. I know he seems a bit too old for this
Yeah, he's literally already says all my back hurts
How do we break a dart board?
Truly again, maybe we take a knife and then he throws the knife instead
No, he notices as soon as I take it right so then what's the table we sit can you pick up the door you can
I
Know
What the dealie it was
Reflings you're gonna have to hold my hand. I don't know what we're doing. Oh
No, no, no, no, that's okay
Don't sit scolera
It said we got to get his
So when he goes to play the harmonica so basically we have to watch him play darts and then he grabs the harmonica
The table is in the back of the pub where mercy got stuck out. We need to set a table whilst that person chases us around
That's severe
Biblically act here at Vichar for Angel. That's actually quite funny
Oh
You didn't get a bull's-eye, but that's okay
No, I wasn't I wasn't doing anything I wasn't doing anything
Oh
We've just a little bad now, okay. He actually recovered from oh, no, he didn't
No, we're sorry
I wasn't really in our attention, but we got it done right. We need to set a table up here
I'm setting a table table table table what table?
this table a
table
The table that mercy got stuck at
Why yes, I am aware of a table mercy got stuck at surely
See any the candlestick also one with the candlestick. I've been able to pick up the candlestick though
Leave me alone. I'm just a little goose in a human world
Not up there is back left
Follow the path under the deck to get to the back
Wait, we're mersey got taken and I couldn't reach
Okay, she come on right let's get these let's get these items. Let's get these items. I know exactly
Yes, you shoot right. We're at the cafe going go go do you cafe go do your cafe stuff exactly right?
I'm gonna grab some stuff. I'm gonna grab anything. I can't okay. I've got the cup for the table
You're gonna grab something too
We're feeling risky. Oh, yeah, I'm gonna get you
No, no, don't chase me out. I need to pick up an item for the
Table that's right. I'm hiding under the table. We're gonna do I'm off-camera
Hmm help sorry, it's fine pick up that candle. You can pick up that candlestick. I think that we need it
Oh, I'm stuck as well this frickin video
The distance thing yeah, oh my god. I'm getting easier. I'm getting pushed out by the guard as well
Bring the guards. This is the best I can do literally is be right under you
They did not make this game easy
Player literally
Have you played it?
How is he chasing you out like this? We're literally all the way inside the rest wrong
Did the old man?
tell them
He is honing in on you can you come under the deck
Okay, you're safe. He should go away. Yeah, he said oh rassen for us and
He's gonna go get a beer
No, he instantly locks on you that doesn't that doesn't seem right that seems too difficult
Follow the
Her man can't catch a break wait. He's looking for his glass, but I broke it
Wait, there's now two people in the cafe area. We need like so much stuff from it
Does he give up
Hope he gives up. Yeah, is there anything we can do on this side? I don't think so
I can see the good sign here. They're gonna move it right here this sign right here. That's the no good sign
I can tell I have gamer instinct. There's a plate over here. Wait. There's already a plate here
There is
Okay, we'll take that and then we'll start getting it set up. Is there anything else I here I can grab?
That's a bucket
Hope I don't break it. No, I don't yeah. Oh, yeah, it's okay
Wow
On my face my face out
My my little goose neck just goes snapped in half
I can't believe he closed on his your face. So red
So what is?
Weird like oh geez old man. You just tried the dark bird
Right, I'm gonna get the salt shaker
Yeah, give me this give me this
Yeah, I said give me this there we go right and then I'll go under the table with you
And then I'll go down the steps and then I can put it on the little table thing and then that's one more
I am ticked off the list. Yeah. Gee. She is
Feral for us right now
Okay, I'm following following. How's your motion sickness levels?
Question mark is a little bad because the camera keeps moving. Okay. Do we need to pause?
We can always I'm very sad. I think we've had a good game in session. We do not actually have yeah
I don't want you to actually be sick
I think it's too much
Please don't be afraid to say no because I can literally meme and chat and ask questions and stuff
So I'm trying I'm trying to to to get through it
Okay, how about we finish this goofy level and then maybe call it there because I don't want you to be sick
Is she gonna be bothered? Probably it. Yeah, okay. Well, great. Right. Let's just check the list to make sure
We need to steal
Glass paint and drop it in the canal. I don't even know where that is. We just need a knife a fork and a candle, okay?
Don't worry. There's a candle there. Oh
She's right. Oh, no, she's dead. Oh that camera angle twaddle in there. She doesn't bother with us. Does she now?
She's just how she's just like
What a curiosity you're breaking up my day. Thank you little geese for showing up
Right, where is this fork?
Sugar
She's gonna see me
No, no, no, no, no, you don't see me. I am a mystery. Oh
I'm out of bones
Give me that. No, no, don't push me that way. Merci's that way. I'm getting pushed out
I'm literally getting pushed out of the camera. I can't like bring you closer to the stairs
Wow
I'm trying to grab the knife game Dave's you really outdone yourself with this one
I think I'm getting shut the knife. I know you're stuck. I am complete. I can't even see myself
Oh, I think I'll hold on here we go
Wait, hold on any snipers shoes basically
Okay, this isn't
Development team didn't you need a hand? Okay. Yes go tie your laces. It's dangerous to go
Wait, I can't even get past bro. You ain't even got the whole mechanic was that he you take your shoes off
Bruh, I'm being trolled so hard this game
Hold on. Let me just move underneath. No, never mind. I'm out of bounds. Yeah, it keeps I can't even get past
Okay, there we go here. Oh, we did it. We did it. We did it. We did it. Go go go. Oh, wait
No, no, no, no, don't send me out again. Don't send me out of bounds again
Oh, wait, it doesn't matter cuz he's chasing you
Well, one of us can I have taken the knife. Oh, no, no, he's got you
Well, sorry, I'm running. Ah
Pick up the knife, please. Okay, there we go. I got it. I got it. Got the knife
And
Run. Okay, we did it. The controls are not nice
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, I can't even see. I'm coming. Can you see me?
Wait, the guy doesn't respond to honking at all. He doesn't care
Oh
He sucks. I don't like him
Oh, no, I have made a grave error go. I need to go underneath or above either one. No, I'm getting pushed out
He's such a bully. Oh, well, I can just sneak over
Can you maybe run please?
Okay, let's hide under here until he stops being aggressive on us. He is like the worst
Yeah, darn it. And bro is not having a knife. No, no, wait. He shouldn't know where it is
I left it on the other side of the fence at the restaurant part
I like at the table but that we set up so it should be fine. Our knife is
Yeah, go away, mr
Stinky go go away, mr. Literally. He's so aggressive against us
This is discrimination. I'll be talking to the bbc
Exactly
I'll be doing a report. I'll be getting interviewers out here
So everyone can learn of your dastardly, right?
Uh, what's this?
Oh, go on. What is it?
I don't know, but I'm pulling
Oh my god, it's how I get a beer. Wait, but I don't have a glass
Sugar. Well, I've got a fork. We need to fork anyway
Let me get out of here with this fork. Wee. I don't know where the glass of beer is though
All right, I'm underneath so she can't get me
Okay, let's we broke it
We did so how on earth did we get well? I did I broke it twice
Ah, I knocked it over. No, no, it's okay. I think it's so tense as long as I found the table. I think it counts
Wow, I'm doing a little 360
All right, it says
A knife and a candle. We actually do have a knife
Right, we just need a candle and we've done this like a really awkward part
Ah
Okay, let's do this brush. There we go
Or do we have to like actually set it?
Like like the fork goes on the left the knife goes on the right type stuff
No, they wouldn't put that in the game. They wouldn't put that right?
I feel like that's like hoity toy. You know your knowledge. Well, I cannot pick up the fork. Is it glitched out?
It says the fork is there. Okay
Still counts. We gotta get the candle now just the candle and then we're done this terrible back and forth section. I think
Where was the hello? Hi
I'm at a coyote
Sorry, I didn't mean to be in your way
Uh, wait, she's pushing me out of the way stinky
You you want to give me all the attention lady, don't you? Yes, you do
Well, uh, quick word word word she put the candle
Uh
Is that the back table again? It may be
I'm just a goose getting all the attention for no oh i'm stuck on her for no particular
Yeah, I'm trying to I'll go under the deck
Oh sugar, okay
You got it
I don't know where it's all in it. Oh my game. Oh game. Just close my game. Just close. Whoa
I have uh, I think you're gonna have to come down these stairs and then come underneath with me here
If I don't get chased out. Yes. Yeah, come this way this way that no no no no
All right, go go go go go go send it send it send it
No
Okay, okay, I think it's okay. I think it's okay mine
I've got the candlestick on
That's the main thing as long as I got the candlestick. I can get you back in all you have to do is unpeel as we
Yeah, you're not coming under here mate
Uh, you may be able to get past
Yeah, you can get back in if I distract him enough and then come under here with me
Oh
The controls the controls. Okay, we're safe. We're safe
The heat is now off of us. Oh, you can see my little red flippers
Oh, I got my little flip-flops
Okay, he has gone back. I think we can now go to the wee restaurant. Okay, okay, let's go
I'm stuck on something. We casually
We're casually strolling. Why is it you're stuck? I'm like
Getting stuck on there. There we go
I don't know. Okay, there we go
We we finally freaking did it. This one was not easy
I think it's the control on the camera. Yeah, this camera angles bending around every two seconds. Good. Oh, I'm stuck again
Oh my gosh. I'm so sorry. Is that vomit burp? I'm getting nervous
And it was the motion sickness burp. I'm so sorry. Is it actually I we can stop
I did not want you to throw up on our first collab
Because I'm afraid the most
Okay, if that was a bomb burp, I'm happy to say we have set the table
Okay, I I'm not gonna make you play anymore. I really do not
I don't want any issues
Okay
We will say thank you so so much to the reeflings and snippets for letting us have an absolute carry on
Unfortunately, we mercy. Um, I
I stupendously, uh, I stupendously asked her to
Play a motion sickness inducing game. I had no idea that the camera angle was so violent towards her per mercy
Um, but I think I think I'm happy to say we'll end it there because I don't want any I don't want any vomit. Okay
Hey, that's the bottom line. Okay. That's the bottom line. No vomit, please
Um, I'm sorry. I don't know. Don't be sorry
Motion sickness burp. I was like, oh, it was so good. I haven't burped yet on stream and then
Yeah
Yeah, no, we'll play it safe. Please do not worry. Uh, let's play it nice and safe
Uh, we will say to the snippets and the reeflings. Thank you so so much for watching
The sneak
Flings
Oh my god, the sneak flings. That's so cute. Thank you so so much for watching us
Um, I am streaming again tomorrow mercy. Are you streaming tomorrow is the real question?
Drum roll. No, actually it's my day off. Oh, well, um, I'll put her to work lads. Don't you worry
I'll make an ASMR for her to put her to work. Don't you funny about that teasing teasing seven to break day
Um, we will leave it there and I'm going to let mercy lie down because I think she needs a good nap
Or maybe a big lie down and some fizzy juice to help her feel a bit better. Um
But thank you so so much for joining me mercy. I appreciate that so much and that was actually genuinely really fun
I had so much fun as chaotic as that game was that was actually hilarious that you started controlling my goose
Oh
Wow, yeah, dairy powers
Literally like I'm not supposed to be the hypnosis one here
Right. Thank you so so much. Ah, thank you. I'm gonna end a little strum
Oh, wait, no no one's streaming because you're the one that normally streams last
Oh, should I let's see if there's is there someone on me check? Let me check with one of the other girls
Let me check if I'm a screaming Azura rated in a use that means she finished her
Cheeky stream her cheeky bricky stream
There are some girls on there's a rain from you may plus and a bunch of
V and new girls are on too. I have no
Uh
I will do a ray from thinking because I don't think she's monetized yet. She needs one watch time. So
Yeah, let's raid I will raid into ray. She's doing unicorn overload number two shipping characters to fight better
What on earth is this girl playing?
um
But uh, uh vanilla wear game. It's supposed to be like really good. Oh, have you played it before or just seen it?
No, I haven't but I I'm uh, I'm a fan of vanilla wear
games
That's cute. Okay. Thank you so so much snifflings. Thank you so so much. Merci for joining me
Please do get some serious rest because I do not want any how terrible is that headline?
Collab results in like vomit
What kind of collab is going on if that's the case?
Right. Thank you. Oh, I missed some I missed some soupas. Oh, yeah. Thank you so much. Um
Misaka best for the 420 blazes stock poose. Hey, thank you so much for the tippy with me. Thank you
The best
We're a five dollar super chat. Did you know rick athly is never gonna give you up never gonna let you down there? We're gonna let
You just never gonna let you down twice never gonna run around absurd you. Yes. I knew that
Thank you so much for the five
Wow
Is that them all thank you so much everyone for for such a wonderful stream and thank you
It was unexpected that we we we hit such a dizzy
I mean we got we got so close though, but I would not have picked that game had I known how spinny camera it was
I thought it was
A straightforward linear
Experience. I do apologize for that oversight. Merci
Um, okay. It's okay. Uh, honestly every everything looked like it was gonna be fine. But like
Yeah, that was every time we entered or moved around somewhere the camera just like violently spins over. So uh, yeah
Sorry to anyone that also has motion sickness watching. You probably feel like merci right now
Okay
Right
I will let you get going. Thank you so so much. Merci. Please. Let's let's put it to the end stream
We'll write into range. Yes. Okay. I'm in stream. Bye. Bye. Reeflings. Bye. Bye. I have rape for us